- He's kinda like the joker.
- We're eating easy
cheese for the first time.
- Cheese that's easy.
- I know that it comes from a can.
And you squirt it
straight into your mouth.
- I think kids at school had it
and it was one of those
things that I wanted
but my mom wouldn't let me have.
- First most American day was
when I got my US citizenship
and then the second one is the day
I get to try easy cheese.
- This is like whip cream basically right?
- We have a choice of
American versus cheddar.
- It says it's made with real cheese,
so that's comforting.
- Also excellent source of calcium.
- Ready?
- Yeah.
- My hand's shaking.
- It's not easy for YB.
- Just a little like half and half.
It's like a little pizza.
(groaning)
- That's a lot of cheese.
I hope that was easy.
- Easy, and a little cheesy.
- A little stick.
Kinda stuck to the roof of your mouth.
- Cheddar.
- What are you doing?
- I'm chopping you with my cheese hands.
- This is easy, I like this.
- This is like a friend activity you know.
- I don't think you should take
this straight to your face.
- Cheese, cheese, cheese!
- This is delicious.
- One, two, three, four,
I declare a cheese war.
- Like a little mountain.
Oh you got pretty far,
you got up to like here.
- Now we do your face.
- Here.
- Touch our tips.
- Don't laugh too much.
- They're connected, look.
- Why so serious?
- I like this cheese.
I would've been in love
with this as a kid.
- Do you feel like your life has changed
for the better today?
- I think my life just got easy.
- Or just got cheesy.
- America's a melting pot
and we're literally exemplifying
that in cheese form.
Just everyone coming to America
all in once, get out of your cans guys.
- Come join the free world.
- Everyone, come join us.
(jazz music)